still no accountability from team biden
no honesty about just why this went so
wrong so fast where are the firings here
with reaction outnumbered co-host kaylee
mcinning is with us and ari fleischer
ari i
we're now at the point you even tweeted
incoherent mumbling bumbling stumbling
this guy can't get through a simple
press conference we've got a problem
we're now going to be honest everybody
can see it the man is a cognitive mess
how does he stay in this job
well it's because of our constitution
our constitution doesn't allow us to
have these type of elections they do in
england when you have a lack of
confidence in a leader we're stuck with
the people's choice unless he resigns
from office and then we have kamala
harris but the midterm elections
that's the america's great well that has
to be invoked by the biden cabinet so i
don't think that's going to happen
but the midterm elections are america's
corrective course for how our democracy
speaks and i think it's highly likely
republicans are going to gain in the
housekeeping in the senate but biden
still is in charge of foreign policy and
that's the problem because we're subject
to his judgment and i think eric asked
the right question
what has joe biden done right
and the answer to that is nothing
everything he has touched and done has
backfired and that's what the american
people are going to have to judge
i was watching a nat geo
911 special last night and you were on
it in that room next to the classroom
where president trump was informed
america is under attack
um you need a leader at moments like
these kaylee
yeah that's right look i just watched
your interview with mark and darren
those two gold star dads my heart goes
out to them both um what they said
should strike fear in the heart of every
american because what they said at base
is this is they talked about president
biden checking his watch what that said
to me is what i was picking up from a
communication standpoint as a former
press secretary this week and that was
this
our commander-in-chief is not
compassionate as he's been billed he's
cruel he he's callous he's not caring he
is callous at base that is what this man
is i watched his abc interview with
george stephanopoulos and he said when
asked about afghans falling off
airplanes that was four or five days ago
he said no one is being killed this was
after many afghans were killed we know
some of the human remains found in a
wheel and his press secretary 48 hours
prior to the attack where 13 servicemen
lost their lives said this was a success
and that was after afghans died this was
after it was known to anyone with common
sense that americans would be left in
this country stranded this is a an
administration that we have to deal with
for the next three plus years it's
horrific because we have a
commander-in-chief and i'm sad to say
this sean it really saddens me to say he
simply does not care
yeah great commentary both of you thank
you kaylee hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else